ah thank you very much
and we love you and i can tell you that
from the bottom of my heart
this has been an incredible four years
uh
we've accomplished so much together i
want to thank all of my
family and my friends and my staff and
so many other people for being here i
want to thank
uh you for your effort your hard work
people have no idea how hard this family
worked
they worked and they worked for you
they could have had a much easier life
but they just
they did a fantastic job i just want to
thank all of you everyone
i want to thank mark meadows who's here
someplace right there i want to thank
mark
but it's been uh it's been something
very special we've accomplished a lot
our first lady has been a woman of great
grace and beauty and dignity
[Applause]
and so popular with the people so
popular with the people in fact
honey would you like to say a few words
please
[Applause]
being your first lady was my greatest
honor
thank you for your love and your support
you will be in my thoughts and prayers
god bless you all
god bless your families and god bless
this beautiful nation
okay
[Applause]
what else has to be said right but what
we've done
that's true honey great job what we've
done has been
amazing by any standard
we rebuilt the united states military
we created a new force
called space force that in itself would
be a major achievement
for a regular administration we were not
a regular administration
we took care of the vets 91 approval
rating they've never had that before the
vets have given us
the va the vets have given us an
approval rating like
has never been before we took care of
our vets and our
beautiful vets they were very badly
treated before we came along
and as you know we get them great
service and
we pick up the bill and they can go out
and they can see a doctor if they have
to wait long periods of time
we got it so that we can sadly
uh get rid of people that don't treat
our vets properly we had we didn't have
any of those rights before when i came
on so our vets are happy our
people are happy our military is
thrilled we also got
tax cuts the largest tax cut and reform
in the history of our country by far
i hope they don't raise your taxes
but if they do i told you so
and if you look at the regulations which
i consider the regulation
cuts to be maybe even more important
that's why we have
such good and have had such good job
numbers the job numbers have been
absolutely incredible when we started
had we not been hit by the pandemic
we would have had numbers that
would never have been seen already our
numbers are
the best ever if you look at what
happened until february
a year ago our numbers were at a level
that nobody had ever seen before
and even now we really built it twice we
got hit nobody blames us for that the
whole world got hit and then we
built it again and now the stock market
is actually substantially higher than it
was
at its higher point prior to the
pandemic so it's
uh really you could say we built it
twice
and uh you're gonna see
you're gonna see incredible numbers
start coming in
if everything is sort of left alone be
careful
very complex be careful but you're going
to see some
incredible things happening and
remember us when you see these things
happening if you would
remember us because i'm looking at
uh i'm looking at elements of our
economy that are set to be
a rocket ship up it's a rocket ship up
we have the greatest country in the
world
we have the greatest economy in the
world and as bad as the pandemic was
we were hit so hard just like the entire
world was hit so hard places that
thought they got away with it didn't get
away with it they're suffering right now
we did something that is really
considered a medical miracle they're
calling it
a miracle and that was the vaccine we
got the vaccine
developed in nine months instead of nine
years or five years or ten years or
a long time it was supposed to take a
long time many many
years to develop a vaccine we have two
out
we have another one coming almost
immediately
and it really is a great achievement so
you should start to see really good
numbers over the next few months i think
you're going to see those numbers really
skyrocket downward and i can only say
this
we have worked hard we've left it all as
the athletes would say we've left it all
in the field
we don't have to
we don't have to come and say we'll
never say in
a month when we're sitting in florida
we're
not going to be looking at each other
and saying you know if we only worked a
little bit harder you can't work harder
and we had a lot of obstacles and we
went through the obstacles
and we just got 75 million votes and
that's a record in the history of
in the history of sitting presidents
that's an all-time record by a lot by
many millions in the history of sitting
presidents it's been
really just an honor one of the things
we're very very proud
of is the selection of almost 300
federal judges and three
great supreme court justices
that's a very big number that's a record
setting number and so we've done a lot
and there's still things to do the first
thing we have to do is pay our respects
and our love
to the incredible people and families
who suffered so gravely from the
china virus it's a horrible thing that
was
put onto the world we all know where it
came from but it's a horrible horrible
thing
so be very careful be very very careful
but
we want to pay great love great love to
all of the people that have suffered
including families who have suffered so
gravely
so with that i i just want to
say you are amazing
people this is a great great country
it is my greatest honor and privilege to
have been your president
[Applause]
from
[Music]
i will always fight for you
i will be watching i will be listening
and i will tell you that the future of
this country has never been better
i wish the new administration great luck
and great success
i think they'll have great success they
have the foundation to do something
really spectacular
and again we put it in a position
like it's never been before despite
the worst plague to hit since
i guess you'd say 1917 over a hundred
years ago
and despite that despite that
the things that we've done have been
just incredible
and i couldn't have done them done it
without you so just
a goodbye we love you
we will be back in some form
[Applause]
[Music]
and again uh i wanted just in
living i want to thank our vice
president mike pence and karen
i want to thank congress because we
really worked well with congress
at least certain elements of congress
but we really did we've gotten so much
done that nobody thought would be
possible but i do want to thank congress
and i want to thank all of the great
people of washington d.c
all of the people that we worked with to
put this miracle together
so have a good life we will see you soon
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much
[Music]
well donald trump there describing his
administration
as a miracle uh boasting about the
achievements
of developing a vaccine in under a year
and saying that
the numbers as he put it of covert
victims will soon be
skyrocketing downward
and now
he's got the music of the village people
uh seeing him off from joint base
andrews as he
heads towards air force one